[Music]
jingle ball very a very exciting who are
you stoked to see tonight everybody but
but I've never seen Sam Smith in concert
I'm introducing the chainsmokers that'll
be incredible to everyone I mean they're
just such good artists you know what's
coming next right what all the Riverdale
questions because that last episode
there was another band you were gonna
throw at me the last episode was so
intense and then it looks like maybe
your character gets out of prison next
week what can you tell me about that
yeah that's exactly what happens and
then it's is it revenge or is it
retribution what's it going to be it's a
good thing he's getting out under dicey
circumstances for sure and he has to
take a job just for parole reasons but
he's deeply involved in what happens on
the Southside find out who is behind the
black hood by end of season I haven't
read we don't have the scripts for the
end of the season yet but from what I've
read not yet who do you think it is do
you have any suspicions
I think it's Alice Cooper I would I
would actually love that that would be
cool
[Music]
you
[Music]